[Music]  great good to see you babe mates do well  you know thanks for having us in there  Norris this is our rehearsal space we've  been working on some stuff special stuff  some not so special self mainly special  stuff mainly we hope you find this  informative exciting  [Music]  one is just too drunk and cause the  power  [Music]  you were here okay all right so we are  about to record three alternative  versions of horny back Youngblood in  light of me you will see it soon  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  it's going to be equally exciting for us  to see when it's done as it is for if  you're a fan of this band so it's  awesome yeah then later watch it  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]